aí tu faz o quê eu faço humor né comédia
eu escrevo crio projetos eu sou ator eu
faço filme ou então vem pra cá fazer um
negócio aqui de Claro você sabe falar
inglês e o inglês eu não sei por que
você não sabe inglês ainda meu pai fala
outra língua mas tem que saber de suma
importância aí pra gente aqui fica
difícil Dá licença um pouquinho garota é
você tudo bom Faz alguma coisa não nada
inglês fluente só vem para cá que ele tá
pensando essa garota é não fico sem
entender o negócio do inglês ó ai eu vou
na Índia Você sabe falar inglês não hein
vai falar inglês porque porque tem que
saber falar cara o inglês mas por que
que todo mundo tem que aprender a língua
de vocês e você não tem que aprender
além de ninguém porque a gente tem um
Mickey Tá bom então tem que aprender
inglês que é importante quem sabe é
importante o mendigo dos Estados Unidos
é melhor do que você que ele fala inglês
e você fala tá bom tá bom vai aprender
Tá bom vou aprender pronto é para falar
inglês não vou falar então tá